in the lobby of the Ramsay Solutions
headquarters Austin is with us hi Austin
how are you doing well Dave how about
yourself better than I deserve where do
you live
I go to school down in Chattanooga
Tennessee from Lewisburg Tennessee Oh
fun Mae UT Chattanooga yes sir
cool what are you studying business
marketing cool and you're here to do a
debt-free scream that's right you're
pretty young to be doing a debt-free
scream just turn 20
I love it all right how much have you
paid off I paid off nine thousand in 15
months way to go
very cool while you're in school yes sir
very good and you said you're studying
what business marketing business
marketing okay and you did that making
what kind of money I made about
twenty-seven thousand dollars during
that 15 months okay very cool and nine
of it went to getting out of debt now
what kind of debt student loans all
students all right and you decide to go
ahead and knock those out and get out of
school debt-free correct what caused you
to go crazy like this you know for me
when I first started getting into school
I took out that 9000 part of it was a
parent loan then they helped me to get
into school and we made an agreement to
do payment plans back and I came back
home for Christmas break in 2013 and we
had an agreement
you know for me to pay a portion of it
but I didn't have the money and it just
drove me nuts and so on December 12 2013
I said I'm gonna be debt-free by 20 and
so it's amazing to be here today and not
only be debt-free I have that six month
emergency fund done to and just have it
all done how did you make twenty seven
thousand dollars while you're in school
full-time over the last 15 months a lot
of work a lot of hours and just really
trying to step my game up in order to
accomplish that goal you know what kind
of work well I started out nighttime
janitor I worked 29 hours a week and
then after that over the summer I was
given the opportunity to run a political
campaign and then with that in that fall
I took a job as a resident assistant at
campus and then I took a couple
internships and then did a couple of
side jobs too while I was in school Wow
I mean you've been going for it and
political campaigns aren't exactly 29
hours a week that was you you were all
hand
on deck that's right yes right so what
you're in school are you I'll be a
second-year junior this fall okay very
cool so you got a year and a half two
years to go yes sir
okay good good good how have your grades
been with all this work you're doing
well it's I would like to seem a little
bit better I just finished up this
semester I think with a 3.8 so I'd
prefer to be at that 4.0 but you know I
hear you well yeah I mean it's not too
bad not too shabby considering how much
you're working especially so how many
hours a week are you averaging do you
think I would say at least forty to
fifty over the 15 months while taking a
full load in school yes sir
okay Superman cape back there somewhere
way to go man
very cool so it's got to feel great to
be able to accomplish all this you know
at first when I paid everything off it
was just something okay well there went
the money that I've worked so hard to
make but then after a while whenever the
fall live events launched and I said wow
he's thinking I got the money to go to
these things so that's when I first hit
me is when I bought the tickets to go to
the entree leadership live event in
Atlanta this fall and then the smart
money event in Nashville that's when it
really hit me I was like this is kind of
cool I don't owe anybody any money so
nobody can tell me what to do anymore
very get your life back well man if you
can you can maintain this idea
throughout the course of your life with
obviously with your work ethic and
ambition you're gonna you're gonna
really be something financially so you
are on an incredible track Austin it's
an honor to talk to you sir thank you
for making the trip up from Chattanooga
to do your debt-free scream what do you
tell people the secret is I mean you got
to be having some cool discussions
around the campus about this yeah I have
I tried to just tell everybody don't let
your surroundings define your outcome as
a college student you know people will
try to sell you anything from a credit
card to a house if you can get the line
of credit just because of how you know
most people don't really think it
through so the key thing for me going
through all this was just don't let
those surroundings don't let everybody
else that's telling you you're crazy
telling you that you need to go spend
some money go eat out on a Friday night
not work 80 hours a week while you're in
school
and so it was for me it was just saying
hey don't let those surroundings to find
you let that your outcome be what you
want it to be well you control your
destiny other people don't and you're
certainly you can't just say well I'm
have to blimp out because I'm 20 I'm
into college or whatever instead you you
went ahead and lived your dream while
you're in the middle of it that's
phenomenal dude very well done very well
done
all right Austin from Chattanooga $9,000
paid off while he's a full-time college
student making fifteen over fifteen
months made $27,000
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one